[Music]
hello there
it's update time once again in fortnite
battle royale and our job is to spot the
changes to the island and link it back
to story
week three of season seven is a beast so
sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap coat adamaru in for your summer
skin purchases
and let's find a bunch of map changes
easter eggs and hidden secrets
okay we can't start anywhere else but
the new drop ships which appear at the
beginning of each loop
if we are lucky enough to be chosen we
will be tractor beamed
into the alien craft and used as an
experiment
each time this happens the experiment
code changes on screen
i'm unsure if this is relevant but i'm
going to make a note of them
just in case it's a message or clues to
the future
then we are transported into this room
equipped with alien tech like a backpack
and gun there's a diplodocus
and sent to gather orbs which in turn
give us loot in reward it's great it's
brilliant it's beautiful
it mixes things up but that's not the
best bit
it's those easter eggs take your time to
look around in here and you'll spot
two of the greatest heroes in fortnite
history
bill and ted the bromance returns
what a journey these two legends have
been on first they were seen back in
season two they fought on opposite sides
during the midas wars
before putting that aside of becoming
the best of friends in a chance
encounter at a roadside cafe
they went on to defeat wolverine that
season that's no joke
and when galactus attacked they sat out
their last moments together
and then we thought they were lost but
then in season 5 we knew this wasn't
true as they could be found in an io
elevator occasionally
looking very confused and now in season
7
they are back they still don't have a
clue what's going on and they look a bit
sad they still rock the colours of their
allegiance but we can confirm the
bromance is going strong
bill and ted are forever they are
inevitable
before i get too hung up on brokeback
mountain here let's look around this
mystery room i'm sure you've noticed
each of these locations is a returning
poi from fortnite's history
back in chapter one we have the pyramid
from sunny steps
we also have the pirate ship from season
seven of chapter one
and more recently we have the famous
butter barn
from moments before the foundation was
enclosed in the zero point
get in there and the iconic theme can be
heard playing
it's a little scuffed but it's worth it
lucky landing is here too after we all
thought that would return in season five
it didn't and then we have this petrol
station this gas station here
i can't figure out why it's here and
what reason it has and what season is it
from
is it from lazy lake or maybe catty
corner am i missing something all the
other locations are iconic and from
history
and this is just a gas station i must be
missing something
before we leave this place something
which could be important to the lore of
the story
look under the floating rocks and you'll
spot this
symbol it's the six sided shape again
we've seen this thing come up
countless times in fortnite history from
the spy locations last season to the
cube
rolling points back in chapter one and
yet again
it returns many people believe this is
the sign of kevin the cube's return
and i kinda hope they're right we now
need to figure
out how to translate this language to
uncover these alien secrets
i think raz will be particularly happy
[Music]
speaking of that image it can also be
found at believer beach
after the update unless like me your
believer beach and holly hedges
never actually appeared thankfully it
came back a few hours later
here at the beach everything we saw
being set up last week is in full flow
the boardwalk is now completely painted
and the truck carrying the entertainment
equipment
arrived and the party is ready to begin
the amount of detail here is really
impressive there's new posters there's
new artwork
and a few man-made ufos and of course a
wacky wavy inflatable tube alien too
what more could you want in life wacky
waving inflatable arm flailing too man
here's something which makes your life
better i think we all need to check
up on the tiny chair if you're new
around here over the past four updates
the chair above the cabin and the lake
has been shrinking slowly we have zero
idea why
and today it has reached a new low it's
minuscule
hashtag tinychair i kinda like dropping
here each game the loot here is terrible
but the law
is immense but now the real question can
it go any smaller than this
we challenge you epic games see you next
update
[Music]
other updates include new npcs to talk
to including a very human guy named bill
at steamystacks i'm totally gonna buy
that skin and
io have been making moves too you can
find a new outpost being constructed at
the center point of the island
analysis of what happened to the zero
point and the location of the foundation
this update also saw these critter
things added and they act like headcrabs
jumping on your face
giving you a speed advantage in return
for a little health
but there's an easter egg nobody is
talking about
if you look closely enough at your
character from the front you can 100
see that you look just like your mom
gorgeous eh
sorry no not sorry all right sorry i'll
be serious
a really funny thing to note is that the
animal wildlife can also be taken over
by those critters
look at a chicken that's got to go on
the thumbnail over at the secret i o
facility
is now an alien ship ready for you to
take from the barn
story wise it looks like io is analyzing
this craft in order to reverse engineer
in the hopes of fighting off the alien
invasion
but you can steal it if that's more your
pace here's a strange one
over at the farm is a questionable
extension i first thought this was
player made
and someone was maybe playing save the
world in battle royale
but this is legit the farmer is
extending his home
and the basic structure is now in place
looks pretty good
hang on could this be the next hot watch
excited noises
oh let's go back a week let's try break
down the cat food mystery
last time we found meowsyl's signature
cat food at the iowa headquarters in the
kitchen above ground
during the week the mystery began to be
fleshed out
one of those updates i missed was down
at the dock the ufo we all noticed
guarded by the io troops was the center
of attention when in fact the crates
down here were filled with cat
food so much cat food we can also spot a
truck about to hit the road and spread
the gift of cat food to the entire
island
many of you guys told me on twitter of
other locations these cat food trucks
can be found
this now has a little more context as
leakers have told us an alien npc
in-game will talk to us about their love
of cat food this felt familiar so i did
a little digging
and i found the movie district 9. have
you ever watched it
in that film an alien race comes to
earth not to overthrow it
but to escape their own dying planet
they are treated like refugees and form
cities together they actually sound just
like the aliens in fortnite right now
as a form of control us humans use cat
food
because these aliens love it and it
looks like fortnite's aliens have the
very same desire to eat that stuff
it's alien catnip i can't find many of
the trucks this week so if you spot them
please give me a shout and i'll include
it next time
and we'll keep following the story of
cat food
fortnite is weird
so that's our update this week what did
i miss please let me know in the
comments i'll be stalking there like
usual
and here's a list of all the legends who
rocked my code adam mario over the last
two weeks
as always please take my thanks right in
your face cheers muchley
i'm adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure i'll see you next time